We Begin our daily cancellation today
with a viral video making the rounds on
social media this is apparently a Tik
Tok influencer named Allison who seems
to have a decent sized following and I'm
not looking to pick on her personally
but she does set us up for a broader
conversation that I think is worth
having because the attitude that she
displays here is certainly not
representative of every young adult
entering the workforce but she does
represent a sizable portion of that
group and if you're in that group uh if
her complaints resonate with you then I
think this segment is for you with that
in mind
here's a video watch I have a bone to
pick with America so I'm headed to my
serving
job I Fu hate
it I hate it why I make more money
serving I have my literal business
marketing
degree that put me in a
cute $80,000 in
debt and I make more serving sushi roll
cuz I was I've been applying to
marketing jobs for weeks now and the the
pay cut is
insane insane but the jobs that are like
a cute 150 to 200,000 a year I'm not
getting those I'm a 20 almost
25-year-old my birthday is soon almost
25-year-old chick going against you know
corporate ass America people with so
much experience all I got is my degree
you know people say get your degree but
then they don't talk about how you need
experience the degree was the
experience I need to
relax okay so there it is now um I'm
going to once again assume my role as
Dad of the internet and give this young
lady and any young person in her
position some advice there are a lot of
young people in her position so I think
uh it's worthwhile so just to restate
The Dilemma Allison has a degree in
business marketing and this is not a
metaphorical degree she tells us it is a
literal degree a literal whole ass
degree as she might say uh she currently
has a job as a waitress which she effing
hates and she wants to land a position
in her chosen field but the problem is
that all the jobs she can get would uh
would pay her less than she makes as a
waitress she's been applying to jobs for
effing weeks now but all the positions
that pay big money 150 200k she can't
get because she doesn't have experience
plus as she says she's competing against
corporate ass America but she feels that
it's unfair because she feels she does
have experience as the degree was the
experience she says now let's uh sort
through this I'm going to try to help
Allison and anyone else in in her bud so
so here's some advice three points first
of all clean up your language young lady
dropping multiple F bombs in a one
minute video makes you sound low class
and stupid you might not actually be low
class and stupid but that's what your
language conveys this is especially true
for women you can say it's sexist all
you want doesn't matter um it's worse
for women men shouldn't be shouting
vulgarities all over the place either
but if you're a woman it makes you look
and sound especially ridiculous it makes
people cringe all the more men
especially are repulsed by foulmouthed
women you should know that and uh
employers especially if they're men are
going to be repulsed by them too so it's
just it's just it's it's repulsive we
don't we don't like
it second I cannot emphasize this enough
never publicly complain about your job I
say it again never publicly complain
about your job it is never a good idea
to declare to the world that you effing
hate your job if I was uh an employer
and my employee made a video announcing
that they hate their job then I would
immediately help them out by relieving
them of this thing that they hate now
it's not that I would be under the
illusion that all of my employees love
their jobs I don't think that I would
see a video like that and say I can't
believe it I thought everyone loves it
job especially if I'm running a
restaurant I I I'd be well aware that a
large percentage of my Workforce hates
being there I used to work at a
restaurant I know that but I expect you
to pretend that you love it it's your
responsibility to pretend that you love
it yes imagine that you you you should
pretend but I don't really feel that way
doesn't matter pretend that you do jobs
are not places for emotional honesty as
an employer I expect you to have a
positive attitude about your job
regardless of how you feel about it
that's because I expect you to have
greater emotional maturity than a
three-year-old and actually even with my
three-year-olds I I I don't accept this
if I tell my children to do a chore and
they are sulking and Sullen and they
stomp their feet I tell them come back
here let's try it again without stomping
your feet but I don't want to do the
chore I don't care if you don't want to
do it you have to do it and you know
what else you're going to do it with a
positive
attitude but this isn't just about the
job you currently have more importantly
if I'm the boss that holds the key to
the better job that you want I am
definitely not going to give the key to
you if you're out there crying about how
you hate your current job in fact if you
come to the interview and even in
private complain to me about your
current job I will not hire you this is
how most employers operate you should
know that if you present yourself as a
whiny sulking complaining sort of person
you're not going to get hired even if
you have reasons to hate your your
former job even if you have the most
valid complaints in the world we all
have valid complaints about our jobs
even if they're valid and you tell it to
your the employee the the person that's
interviewing for the new job you're
probably not going to get the job you
know why because why would anybody want
to bring your bad attitude into their
environment bad attitudes are a virus a
sickness they destroy morale I'm not an
employer but I can tell you that I don't
want anyone on my team who has a bad
attitude I want people who are ambitious
eager who want to be there they want to
be where they are they want to keep
moving up in the world if I have someone
on my team who seems to not like being
there then they're not going to be there
for very long I don't want to be around
that this is why you should never
complain about your job in any context
where a current or future potential
employer might hear you if you want to
move up in the world present yourself as
eager ambitious positive and grateful
even if you aren't really that kind of
person pretend that you are and after a
while you may even convince yourself
that you actually are eager ambitious
positive and grateful which will mean
that you've really become all of those
things this is known as the fake it till
you make it approach and I'm here to
tell you that fake it till you make it
is in many ways the key to success in
life believe it or not if there's one
cliche that you should cling on to that
will help you through life it is that
one fake it till you make
it third your generic business marketing
degree is mostly worthless I'm afraid
you have every right to be frustrated by
that I would be if I was in your shoes
the system lied to you you were duped
they charged you a lot of money for this
piece of paper uh they told you it would
unlock all kinds of opport unities and
now you're discovering that it doesn't
exactly work that way it's not that
simple why well because the fact that
you sat in classrooms and learned about
business marketing in textbooks does not
not mean that you actually have any
skill or ability in any field related to
that very Broad and somewhat ambiguous
category bulletproof everyone is a
premier American Body Armor manufacturer
and supplier their unique armor systems
offer 25% more coverage than standard
armor while maintaining flexibility and
wearability bulletproof everyone is
designed for everyday wear their their
ultra light armor system is so light and
thin that you might just forget you're
wearing it your safety and discretion is
their top concern unless someone uh puts
their hands on you no one will know that
you're wearing body armor with
bulletproof everyone you're not a
walking billboard there are no visible
logos no flashy designs the clothing is
designed to make you blend in not stand
out which is what it should do whether
for work or for Play Bulletproof
everyone has the perfect armor system to
fit your lifestyle and your budget right
now my lers can get 10% off plus plus
free bulletproof backpack with the
purchase of any bulletproof clothing go
to bulletproof everyone.com use code
Walsh to check out that's bulletproof
everyone.com promo code Walsh employers
look at your business marketing degree
and it tells them nothing about you you
could be a brilliant ambitious
Innovative highly skilled genius with a
business marketing degree you could be
or you could be an incompetent lazy
with a business marketing degree
either sort of person can get a business
marketing agree and there are sadly many
more in the latter category than in the
former which actually is not that sad
come to think of it because if you are
competing in the job force in the job
market the fact that there are so many
incompetent lazy Sad Sack sort of people
is an advantage for you it makes it even
less difficult to uh get a leg up over
them and what all that means is that you
need to prove yourself in your chosen
industry the same way as anybody else
you have to start at the bottom
and work your way up your degree is not
work experience Al Allison it doesn't
count your degree only proves that you
have experience getting degrees you are
very qualified to go out and get a
business marketing degree so you have
experience doing that but as for
performing in an actual job getting real
world results you have not demonstrated
any aptitude there your degree doesn't
prove your abilities in that area one
way or another and I realize this is
disappointing to hear but you just have
to accept it and get on with it you're
going to have to start at the bottom of
the ladder and climb your way up you
thought you thought like so many other
graduates you thought that the degree
was an elevator that would take you to
the top floor effortlessly and
automatically while you look down and
pity all of those poor wretches trudging
up the steps one step at a
time but now you find yourself at the
bottom of the same
staircase one of those poor wretches
yourself the place you never wanted to
be you thought the degree would get you
out of that and now now here you
are except with a lot of debt weighing
you
down you don't like that which is fine
you don't have to like it nobody would
but nobody cares if you like it or
not now you just have to decide if
you're going to get moving or stay at
the bottom of the steps whining while
life passes You by no one's going to
hand you a $200,000 salary you have to
earn that and yes it might mean taking
an opportunity in the short term that
pays you less than you could make
working tip for tips at a
restaurant imagine that that's part of
that's part of being a successful person
sometimes you take an opportunity where
where it's it it seems worse than what
you had before but you're doing it for
the long term because you have a
strategy in
mind uh it's a you're losing the battle
to win the war type of
situation that was my situation when I
first started working in media pretty
much the lowest possible level I wasn't
even at the Bottom Rung of the ladder I
was beneath the ladder down in the
basement and I was earning less and that
time that I had a few years earlier as a
teenager delivering
pizzas but these are the kind and I
could have just and if I if all the
matter you know if I if I had the same
attitude as Allison I would have said
well I'm just going to keep delivering
pizzas i' made more money doing this and
you know what I'd be doing right now
delivering pizzas i' still be
there but these are the kinds of
sacrifices you have to make and risks
you have to take if you want to succeed
I keep using the latter analogy but
that's probably not the most accurate
image because the path to success any
kind of su success in any area of life
is not a simple linear movement from
point A to point Z with each step
bringing you clearly closer to your goal
actually the path involves going up and
then going down again then going up
higher than you were for and then a
little down a little bit and so on and
so on it's less a ladder and more like
Shoots and
Ladders now we would all prefer if this
was not the case it would be nice to
live in a world where the next job you
get after serving sushi rolls always
paid better than the one you had before
it would be nice if you could uh hang
out in in college for four years party
most of the time get a low effort degree
like business marketing and then be
handed a corporate job with a corner
office and at $850,000 salary at the age
of 24 that would be pretty
great what a world that would be
unfortunately that's not the world we
live in or will ever live in and if you
want to succeed in this world you need
to deal with its realities so to review
clean up the language stop complaining
about your job don't waste your money on
a generic worthless degree and if you
already did waste your money then I'm
sorry about your luck you got screwed
that's it it happened it's you can't
can't change it now but either way you
have to start at the bottom and climb
your way up painstakingly one step at a
time and pretend that you like it the
whole way up that's the way there is no
other way so get on with it or else you
are today canceled thanks for checking
out this video if you'd like to listen
to my full podcast on the go you can
check out the Matt wall show on Apple
podcast Spotify or wherever you get your
podcasts